تعد تقنيات [الموسيقى] الأجنبية
منصة مثيرة
لأنه يمكن دمجها بسلاسة
في جلد الإنسان على عكس
التقنيات المتغيرة الأخرى،
ولا تتطلب هذه المنصة أي مكونات إلكترونية،
فالتقنيات التي تصممها
متوافقة مع جسم الإنسان
[الموسيقى]
لذلك إذا نظرنا إلى  الوشم، لذا فقد
تغير لونه تمامًا من الأزرق
إلى الأخضر في الوقت الحالي، لذا فهو تحول
يمكن ملاحظته بالعين البشرية، لذا فإن التلألؤ
البيولوجي ظاهرة شائعة
في الطبيعة المرصودة، لذلك قد
يشمل هذا اليراعات ومجموعة واسعة من
الحيوانات البحرية، لذلك وشمك  سوف
يتوهج ويتغير لونه بشكل أساسي
استجابة للتغيرات الأيضية في
جسمك البشري
الخارجي
[موسيقى]
لن يكون من الممكن تنفيذ
هذه التقنية في صالون الوشم التقليدي
ولكن يمكن تنفيذها في
إعدادات المستشفى لذلك ستحجز
موعدًا لها  مثال مع
طبيب الأمراض الجلدية الخاص بك للوشم أو حقن
أجهزة الاستشعار الحيوية للوشم إذا كنت
متحمسًا حقًا لمستقبل العلوم الحيوية
والتقنيات ونشعر أن هذه
التقنيات يمكن أن تكون مفيدة جدًا
للمرضى في جميع أنحاء العالم
الأجانب